Angus con, the name that is synonymous
with barbaric, cruelty and conquest.
800 years ago, he created the greatest
army the world has ever known.
Wielding it with tactical brilliance to
lay claim to the largest empire in world
history.
No other man Alexander and Napoleon or
Hitler ever came close to the level of
success and conquest over
the Mongolian man of steel.
So how did he do it? Well,
in today's biographics,
we discover how he simple peasant arose
from one of the harshest environments on
the planet to take the world by storm.
What we know about the early life
of this man, he would rise to rule.
The world comes from an accounts called
the secret history of the Mongols
written. Soon after he
died, it tells us the gang.
Gus was born somewhere in
the steps of Central Asia.
Around the year 1165 it is said that
he was born with a clot of blood in his
hands, which was seen as
important of great things to come.
Can I get some was born into
a harsh unforgiving world.
The Mongols who lacked a common chief.
We're broken into a number of clans who
were constantly warring with each other.
The landscape was vast and rugged,
situated between Europe and China.
It consisted of an inhospitable series
of rolling hills, rocky outcrops,
and freezing temperatures.
The Chinese referred to the region as the
barbarian wilderness and built a great
wall to keep its inhabitants from reading
their border regions for the Mongols
strength was found in numbers.
Large families were encouraged with
polygamy and accepted custom gang gets.
His father had two wives.
The boy's mother had been abducted from
her previous husband in another tribe as
a boy. Ganglius grew up with three
brothers, a sister and two half brothers.
His earliest years were spent hunting,
writing and roaming the plains as part
of Eaton nomadic society. As clan,
we're constantly on the move seeking new
pastures whenever the grazing for their
sheep was exhausted.
Ganga is reported.
To have grown up as a brave and define
young man is only fear being dogs. Yes,
he was an introvert who preferred to
spends the bulk of his time alone with his
thoughts.
He was fiercely independent.
Seeing no value in consultation with
others as he emerged into his teens.
It was a parents too old that he had a
sense of his own destiny and that destiny
lay far beyond the clan.
That was then as well as was the custom
at around nine years old gangsters.
Parents arranged a marriage for their son.
His wife to be was named Burton,
who was from a neighboring tribe and gangs
was to be transferred to that camp so
that he could grow up
alongside his bright.
On the return trip after delivering
his son Gangas, his father,
I'm at a party of Tata,
has on their way to a hunting expedition.
They seemed hospitable offering and
food and drink. However, the offerings,
they were laced with poison and
three days later his father died.
Gang gets quickly returned
to the father of this family.
They were abandoned by
the rest of the clan.
His mother Harlene now assumes the
mantle of headship within the household.
There was constant friction between
the three sons of how the Nams,
they're two stepbrothers, one
a. When he was 13 years of age,
Angus was holding a fish
that he had caught when one
of his stepbrothers came up
and snatched it from his
hands without hesitation,
Gingiss drew his bow and killed the boy.
This was the first clear demonstration
of the absolute ruthlessness that would
come to characterize the boy
who would become the great con.
By the age of 15 ganglius was stronger,
bigger,
and it's more skillful in hunting
and horsemen shift than his brothers.
His brothers began to bow to him.
There's then natural leader,
his reputation as a strong warrior.
It began to spread soon,
the clown that had deserted his
family when his father had died,
got to hear if there's some start fearing
that he might lead as brothers against
them. He decided to take the initiative
by invading the family's encampments and
taking gangas captive.
The Angus was able to escape the invaders,
fanned out into the wilderness and
nine days later they found him.
Gang guest was taken prisoner and they
heavy wooden yoke was placed around his
neck a couple of days later,
and while is was languishing inside,
a guarded tends with the
yolk still around his neck.
His captors through a celebrator he party,
despite the inconvenience of the oak
gang guess managed to overpower is God.
He got down to the river before
his absence was discovered,
unable to traverse the river
while wearing the yoke.
He then returned to the tense
from which he had come there.
He found the guard we
had recently overpowered.
Ganga is then displayed the shrewdness
of thinking, which was to set him a pass.
He told the guards that's unless he got
him out of the yoke and gave him a horse.
He would tell the others that
the guard had helped him escape.
The black nail worked until he was
soon galloping away from his captors.
A year later at age 60 and getting us
to return to the village of Berta girl,
he had been pledged to at the
time of his father's death.
It was time to get
married as a wedding gift.
The girl's father gave him a spectacular
sable coat. The next day, gang gets,
took his wife back to his encampments
and left her in the care of his mother.
He then wrote off to a neighboring clan
where he presented his new code has a
gift of the chief Dean by the name
of Todd rule. In doing so, again,
this was purchasing the allegiance
of this powerful clan leader.
He asked or grill to help him win back
the loyalty of the tribesmen who deserted
his family after his father's death to
roll with sympathetic and it's impact was
formed between them.
News of the alliance,
it seems spread of the clans offered
their support and before long Gingiss was
able to call upon the formidable force
for four years before he could put them
into action. However, disaster
struck invading market.
Horseman came thundering across
the plains intent on kidnapping.
The women of Ganga says camp. The
majority of the clown managed to escape,
but again gets his young wife.
Bertha was taken captive by the markets
gangas desperately road for the camp of
to grow for help.
Doggerel announced that he would ride
upon the markets and destroy them
returning butter to our husbands.
Over the next few months,
the alliance managed to bring together
more than 5,000 warriors in order to ride
with them.
The attack was swift and decisive.
The Mongol hoards decimated
the market camp killing,
looting and pillaging without mercy.
In the midst of the campus,
they found butter.
She had been raped repeatedly and was
pregnant shortly after returning to camp.
She gave birth to a son,
but it was never known if
it was gangbusters child
or one of the market rate
tests
in the wake of the overthrow of the
market's Gingiss went from strength to
strength. He United with the clan
of his boyhood friends Jamica.
The two men became inseparable,
decluttering themselves. Blood brothers,
they lived together, ate together
and slept together. This rouse,
the jealousy of Ganga says wife and
mother who began to spread rumors about to
Jamaica and then just having
to do drive the two men apart.
Whether it was the influence of the
women in his life or his own lust for
absolute power.
Something caused Gingiss to sever the
bond with [inaudible] in 1185 the two
plans worth moving towards.
First,
our grazing grounds when in to scientists
to turn off and camp in a valley he
called to Ganga is to join him again,
gets ignored him and kept on writing,
carrying on a mile or so.
He turns in his saddle to see if there's
not only had his own kinsmen followed
him first as many of Jammu
because men had as well.
Ganglius was now developing the largest
following of any of the mongrel plants.
This was achieved poly through the design
for security and numbers and partly by
coercion.
Those who did not agree to give ganglius
their religions while they were forced
to do so.
The combination of his desire for power
and wealth and his need to feed his ever
expanding, following led to
repeated raids on other clams.
The capture if they're women ans
the plundering of their belongings.
The secret history of the Mongols
attributes equates to Gingiss,
which may be familiar to fans of the 1982
movie Conan the barbarian in which the
words were given to Arnold
Schwarzenegger's character.
The greatest pleasure is to vanquish
your enemies and chase them before you to
rob them of their wealth and see those
dear to them bathed in tears to ride
their horses and clasp to your bosom.
That wives and daughters at this point,
still in his early twenties Ganga said
already proved themselves to be brilliant
at psychological warfare.
He would attack a tribe with horrific
and devastating force in order to
intimidate the surrounding camps to
give up without a fight. As a result,
many thousands of his enemies simply
surrendered in order to avoid the carnage
that would result if they resisted.
Having subjugated ends melded into one
the disparate Mongol clans Gingiss now
set his sights on the furthest reaches
of the barbarian wilderness among those
who had not yet joined as alliance
was his former best friend, Jabuka,
who was now his mortal enemy.
The people of the two camps that have
been able to maintain a sort of uneasy
peace.
However,
one day a disagreements over grazing
lands erupted into violence with one of
Ganga says men killing a warrior from
Jim Lucas camp and outrage to Mooka
reacted by attacking the much larger
camp of Ganga the unexpectedness and
lightening speed of the rage resulted in
the killing of many and the capture of
70 of Ganga says chief teens who were
taken back to Jim Lucas camp where they
were tortured and boil the live gang gets.
He was shocked to his core
at this humiliating defeat.
He came to the realization that his
army was not yet ready to engage in the
large scale conquests that he
had envisioned. Consequently,
he sat out to to mold them into a
war machine, a breed of warrior,
the likes of which had
never been seen before.
The army that resulted was incredibly
mobile able to travel an average of 70
miles per day.
The men were subjected to the most
severe discipline in order to forge their
minds and bodies into warrior like steel.
Before long the reputation,
the barbarian super army spreads
beyond the boundaries of Mongolia.
When the rulers of the Chin
Empire in China heard about them,
they invited Gingiss to come and
help them fight off marauding bands,
the Tatas who were
constantly harassing them.
The toss is also a longtime enemies of
the Mongols and Ganga saw this as an
opportunity to exact vengeance while
expanding his reach internationally.
In short order,
the overpowering force of the Mongols
crushed the Tatas resending to try and in
their home country gangbusters army.
It was immediately attacks by Jim
Lucas forces. This time, however,
Gingiss was ready over a series of three
bloody encounters, Jamaica's followers.
We're finally subjugated Jamaica,
however,
managed to escape fleeing to
the sanctity of the Nyman's,
say powerful tribe dwelling and the
northwesterly region of the steps.
When news reached to Ganglius,
the Jamica joining the name and he
set his sights on destroying them,
he unleashed his 80,000
strong cavalry against them,
totally overpowering them in a frenzy
of blood Lessing amazingly, however,
Jimmy kept managed to escape.
Once again,
he had with a small cloud
of mountain dwellers.
They fearing the wrath of the invaders
betrayed Jamoca and handed him over to
the camp of Gingiss.
Gingiss.
Though he was sharp's by the
lack of loyalty to Jameka.
Mandy had them all slaughtered.
Then he extended mercy to Jamaica
with an offer of a pardon but true.
Mooka refused and begged
to be put to death.
A seeding to his wish can guess allowed
his old friend to be suffocated to death
inside a carpet. Despite his
reputation as an unfeeling execution,
Gingiss turned away
unable to watch the scene.
Having the feeds of the Nyman's Gangas
was now the supreme ruler of in excess of
2 million people. Having had a taste
of supreme power, he now wanted more.
That was still positive Mongo there
that were not part of his empire.
These were areas along the eastern
and southern regions of the country.
Over a period of months,
he systematically beat into submission
those who had not yet come under his yoke,
Ganga [inaudible] road at the very front
of his ferocious towards personally
overseeing every detail of the attack,
but his greatest skill and ability to
handpick brilliant generals. In doing so.
He managed to United people who had for
centuries been a war with one another in
1206 the people made Gingiss best supreme
ruler bestowing upon him the title of
Con, the Great Leader as recorded in
the secret history of the Mongols.
The people proclaimed,
we will make you a leader are great con.
We will fling ourselves like
lightening upon your foes.
We shall give you the fairest to girls
from the enemy. If we disobey you,
take our flocks and our wives and our
children and throw while worthless heads
upon the sands between military conquests,
Skanga enjoy the rewards of success.
He gathered more wives and had more
children by his first wife about it.
He had four sons who would each be given
rulership over a part of his empire.
Despite the wealth, luxury, and family
with which he now surrounded himself.
Gangas was tormented by vivid dreams in
which he was continually riding in the
conquest of one land after another
impels by these dreams and his own innate
ambition,
he became fixated on the vast lands
that lay beyond the Great Wall on our
southern.
In 12 days.
Six gangas cool.
Together a great summit of his generals
and tribal leaders to discuss his
planned invasion of China
between Mongolia and China.
Neva kingdom [inaudible]
the land of the time goods.
This was a key trade where between
the Central Asia and the West,
Gangas undertook a campaign of conquest
that within two years brought the entire
kingdom of [inaudible] under his domain
the way it was now open to invade China
and an effort to capitalize on his
previous dealings with the Chin Empire
concent, a peace envoy over the
wall, Jen authorities. However,
they were suspicious of the
visitors and they put them to death.
On hearing of this outcome.
Gingiss took two is tense and fasted.
For three days he emerged to announced
that the heavens declared that he would
be victorious and the time
to wreak vengeance upon the
chin was now with 40,000
cavalry men riding behind him.
Gangas crossed the border,
smashing over the wall and into China.
They then swept down upon the Chin Empire.
They approached with unrivaled speed and
quiet until almost upon the enemy when
the thundering of their horses
hooves shook the grounds,
the attacks that followed
were overwhelming,
crushing their enemies and
destroying their encampments.
It was during the Chin campaign that
the ruthlessness of Ganga Eskom became
legendary. He would use captured women
and children as human shields in battle,
forcing them to march ahead of his army
as they approached an enemy village.
Within two years of first invading China,
Ganglius had reached the Capitol
or lift the Chin Emperor John Do,
which is modern day Beijing,
the great city.
It was encircled by a wall and strongly
fortified Colin's army laid siege for
almost a year. Finally, with the
aid of siege towers and catapults,
the Mongols manage to breach the wall
after a fierce battle and that the cost of
thousands of Chinese lives,
the city fell off to subjugating the chin.
Emperor gang guest rode back to
the step country of his birth,
but it wasn't long before the spirit of
conquest. One small fired his ambition.
He now looks to the worlds beyond China.
He looked to the fringe of
Europe between China and Europe,
lay the vast Islamic
empire known as Kora San.
This area was ruled by a Shaw who had
power that equaled that of the Ganga is
himself, but calm, did not wish to
subjugate the lands of the shop.
He sold only peace sending a caravan
of envoys to acquire a satin. Yes.
Just after they crossed the border,
all of his men,
they were captured and
slaughters and enraged.
Angus sends another group of envoys this
time instructing them to go directly to
the shop.
They too were murdered by Islamic
soldiers for Gingiss who believed in the
absolute inviolability of envoys.
This was far too much time for
vengeance was once again his hands.
He says out at the head
of his largest army,
to date more than 200,000 man years of
savage butchery were unleashed upon the
Muslim people.
By the time the bloodletting subsided,
Gingiss Carlton had wrestled absolute
power away from the shop is vast empire
now spans from the Yellow Sea and the
east all the way to the Caspian and the
west
before attending to the steps.
Can Guess Khan and pointed his
son who good day is the APP.
He now face the problem of
controlling his vast empire.
In the summer of 1226 he wrote to the
head of a 180,000 warriors to crush an
uprising among the time good people
before he goes to them. However,
he fell from his whole since suffered
serious injuries and didn't turn or
bleeding over the coming months.
He only got worse on August the 18th
1226 and at the height of his powers he
died Ganga scarves, legacy. It would be
cemented by his grandson, Kublai Khan,
who extended the Mongolian Empire to
encompass two continents and to become the
largest empire in history. Perhaps gardens
most enduring contribution, however,
was this, although forge
through unspeakable violence,
his conquests brought about a peace and
stability that's enabled the first ever
flow of trade and ideas between
the eastern and Western worlds.
So I really hope you found
that video interesting.
If you did hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday or so over there on the
rights and other videos from the archives,
which you can definitely check out.
And if you want us to do a biography on
a certain person had over to our website,
that's the best way to do it. You can find
a link to it in the description below,
and then in the bar you'll see
like a voting area. Go over there,
suggest someone to us, and we're going
to make them more popular ones. So we're,
we're open to your feedback and as always,
thanks for watching.